Çeviri: Erman Turkmen
Gözden geçirme: Gözde Caymazer
Cem Topçuoğlu
Kolektif Yaratıcılık Başkanı
Bazı insanlar vardır, hepimiz tanırız.
Herhalde herkes tanıyor.
(Alkış)
Çünkü onlar çok özeldir?
Onlar, aslında bazı yeteneklerle doğarlar
ve o yetenekler herkeste olmayabilir.
Onlar ünlüdür, onlar stardır.
Bazı insanlar vardır,
belki hepimiz tanımayabiliriz.
Tanıyanınız var mı?
Çok görmüyorum.
Onlar çünkü çok tanınmak da istemezler ve
sahnenin biraz gerisinde olurlar hep.
Ben çok iyi tanıyorum.
Sonradan daha da çok tanımaya başladım,
kaybettikten sonra.
Yıllar geçtikçe daha da tanımaya başladım.
Aslında o Nazım'ın sevgili
-daha sonra karısı olan-
aşkı Piraye'nin oğlu
daha önceki evliliğinden.
Bu edebiyat dünyasının
içinde yaşamış birisi.
Mehmet Fuat.
Onu edebiyatçılar Mehmet Fuat diye bilir,
biz sporcular Mehmet Bengü diye tanıyoruz.
Aslında Mehmet Fuat, hep edebiyat
dünyasının içinde oldu ve
Nazım da kendisine sahip çıktı
1935'lerde, o dönemde.
Tabi ki böyle bir dünyanın içinde yaşayan
insan, daha sonra edebiyatın içinde oldu.
Hep hayatımızda oldu, edebiyat hayatında.
Yayın evleri kurdu,
yayın evlerini yönetti.
Genel yayın yönetmenlikleri yaptı.
Şiirler yazdı, eleştiriler yaptı.
Aslında edebiyat dünyasındaki gençlere
mentorluk yaptı yıllarca.
Uzun yıllar.
Ama Mehmet Fuat benim hayatıma
başka bir yerde girdi Mehmet Bengü olarak.
1970'lerin ortasında aslında O,
edebiyat dünyasının dışında
kendisi spora çok meraklıydı.
Özellikle futbola çok meraklıydı.
Futbol oynamak istiyordu fakat maalesef
çocukluğundaki bir takım hastalıklar
-özellikle ciğerleriyle ilgili- onu
futbol oynama hevesinden
vazgeçirmek zorunda kaldı.
Ama kendisi o kadar enteresan
bir kişilikti ki futbolla ilgili
bir şeyler yapmak istiyordu.
Edebiyatçı kişiliğinin yanı sıra aslında
bulunduğu semtte -Altunizade semtinde-
birtakım arkadaşlarıyla beraber,
50'li yılların sonunda
ilginç bir kulüp oluşturdular.
Bir spor kulübü.
Aslında belki de spor kulübünün dışında
bir aile, bir mahalle kulübü diyebiliriz.
Ama futbolu mahalle çocuklarının
sokakta birbirleriyle oynayıp
birbirleriyle kavga dövüş etmelerinden
çok, spora onları yönlendirip
onları birer futbolcu
yapmaya heveslenmişti.
Ama bildiğimiz tarzda futbolcu değil.
1950-60'lardan bahsediyorum. O dönemlerde
çok farklı futbol kültürleri bilinmiyordu.
Ama Mehmet Fuat, edebiyatçı, araştırmacı
ve her zaman her şeyi merak eden
bir kişilik olarak dünyadaki
futbol kitaplarını getirtti.
İngiliz futbol adamlarının
kitaplarını okudu.
Bir futbol klasiği, kolektif bir yaratıcı
futbol tekniği geliştirdi mahallede.
Bunu mahalle çocuklarıyla,
küçükten başlayarak onları yetiştirdi
ve kısa zamanda tüm semtlerde,
mahallelerde hatta İstanbul'un genelinde
bu takımdan bahsediyordu herkes.
Bir futbol takımı kurulmuş ve inanılmaz
kolektif bir futbol oynuyor.
Bugüne kadar görülmedik
bir futbol oynuyor.
Daha sonra bu takım Fenerbahçe,
Galatasaray takımlarını yenip
İstanbulspor'la berabere kalınca,
birdenbire herkes ne oluyor burada diye
birbirine sormaya başladı.
Ama maalesef o günlerde de futbolda
şiddet vardı, mahallede şiddet vardı ve
futbolun bu şiddeti
Mehmet Fuat'ı biraz yıldırdı.
Bir mahalle maçı sırasında olan bu şiddet
olaylarından sonra futbolu bırakıp
kulübü, şiddeti en aza indiren ve
takım oyununu en üst düzeyde
oynamaya elverişli voleybola çevirdi.
Bütün fokusunu voleybola verdi ve bu semt
çocuklarına voleybol öğretmek istedi.
Hiçbir şeyden haberi yoktu.
Aslında voleybolun
V'sini bilmiyordu belki de.
Ama yine merakı, bütün dünyadaki
kitapları araştırması ve
voleybolu kitaplardan öğrenerek
bu çocuklara anlatması gerekiyordu.
Kendine böyle bir hobi veya
böyle bir mahallede görev edinmişti.
Gerçekten Mehmet Fuat bunu başardı.
Genç, küçük, minik takımlarla
başladığı macerasını o dönemdeki
deplasmanlı lige kadar
bu takımı çıkartıp devam ettirdi.
Nasıl böyle bir şey
yapabiliyordu Mehmet Fuat?
Hiç bilmediği edebiyatçı kişiliğiyle
birdenbire sporcu kişiliğine
nasıl geçmişti?
Nasıl becermişti bunu?
Aslında hiç bilmediğiniz bir işi
acaba alıp sıfırdan
yapabilir miydiniz okuyarak,
merakta bulunarak?
Ben de reklamcı doğmadım.
Reklamcılık okuluna da gitmedim.
Hep mühendis olmak istiyordum,
tesadüfen bu sektörün içine geldim.
En ufak bir yaratıcı
yeteneğim yoktu, hala yok.
(Gülüşmeler)
Hiç olduğunu ve
olacağını da zannetmiyorum.
Ama meraklıydım galiba biraz.
Mehmet Fuat'tan belki öğrendiğim
onun vizyonunun açıklığından
etkilendiğim bir taraf vardı
muhtemelen ve o tarafımı geliştirmeye,
devamlı bir şeyleri öğrenmeye,
madem bu sektörün içine girdim
ben de bu işi iyi yapabilirim herhalde
diye kendimi hep zorladım.
Aslında Mehmet Fuat'tan başka bir şey
daha öğrenmiştim sanırım.
Bu belki de bizim sektörde çok olan,
belki birçok sektörde çok olan
hep starlara karşı -ben star olmadığım
için veya öyle doğmadığım için veya
öyle yeteneklerim olmadığı için-
bir şekilde mücadele etmek gerekiyordu.
Aslında Mehmet Fuat bunu kolektif
takım oyunuyla çözmüştü.
Dünyadan o günkü voleybolda
-Türkiye'de voleybol oynayanlar bilir-
çok klasik, daha çok starların
üzerine giden, köşeden oynanan
yüksek voleybol, yüksek top atılır ve
smaçörler vururdu ve sayı alınırdı.
Çok klasik bir oyun oynanıyordu.
Halbuki o yine araştırarak daha hızlı,
daha kısa insanların da oynayabileceği,
göze hoş gelen ama müthiş hızlı ve
karşı tarafı aldatmacalı
yeni bir voleybol ekolü
getirmeye çalışıyordu Türkiye'ye.
Çünkü O'nun ancak o takım oyunuyla
doğru insanları bir araya getirip
starları yenme şansı vardı.
Galiba biz de biraz benzer şeyler
yaptık ajansta.
Biz de aynı şekilde iyi oyuncuları
toplamaya çalıştık.
Hatta birlikte "Yaratıcılık da Yaratılır"
diye bir kitap yazdık birkaç sene önce.
Kitabın önsözünde bu yazıyordu.
Yani biz starları bulup onlarla değil,
biz kendi starlarımızı yaratıp
onları kolektif yaratıcılık olarak
toplayıp öyle hareket edip
öyle başarılı olmaya çalışacağız diye.
Bir başka şey daha vardı.
Bu ekibi kurarken nasıl kuracaktınız?
Ekip kurmak ve söylemek kolay
teklere karşı mücadelede ama
bu ekibin içindeki insanların
kim olduğunu bilmeniz çok önemli.
Kim olduğunu derken bazen
yanılgıya düşüyor insanlar.
Ben de düştüm yıllarca.
Sonradan belki bu eski aklımda kalan
Mehmet Fuat hikayelerinden
çözmeye çalıştım bazı şeyleri.
İnsanların kim olduğunu
bilirdi Mehmet Fuat.
Bizim annemizi, babamızı tanırdı,
derslerimizi bilirdi.
Hangi mahalleden
oraya geldiğimizi bilirdi.
Fakir olduğumuzu, zengin olduğumuzu,
nasıl bir sosyoekonomik gruptan
geldiğimizi, psikolojimizi bilirdi.
Çünkü kulübün içine girdiğinizde
bir takım oluşturmak istiyorsanız
o takımı eşitlemeniz gerekiyor.
Herkesi eşit bir platformda buluşturmanız
gerekiyor ki takım olabilesiniz.
Bu insanları tanımadan
takım olmanız mümkün değil.
Mehmet Fuat bunu biliyordu ve
bunu çok doğal olarak yapıyordu.
Biz de aynı şeyi yaptık
ajansta ilk kuruluşta.
Bir takım mentorler de kullanarak
çalışanlarımızın kim olduğunu
tek tek öğrenmeye çalıştık.
Düşünsenize hepiniz
şirketlerde çalışıyorsunuz.
Sabahleyin onlarca, yüzlerce insan
şirketlerinize geliyor
İstanbul'un farklı bölgelerinden;
Rami'den, Bakırköy'den
Bağdat Caddesi'nden, Bebek'ten,
apartmandan, evden, zengin ortamdan,
fakir ortamdan, gecekondudan.
Bu insanlar modern, farklı bir ortama
giriyorlar -kendi yaşamadıkları aslında
belki birçoğu- ve sonra da oradan
çıkıp gidiyorlar.
Bu insanları nasıl motive edip
ekip yapıp çalıştıracaksınız tanımadan?
Bunu çok iyi öğretti Mehmet Fuat.
Burada bir başka konu da
nasıl bunu kültürleştirdiği.
1977-78 seneleri sanıyorum,
kulübe geldim antrenmana.
Mehmet Fuat'ı yine gördüm kulübü
temizlerken elinde süpürgeyle.
Çok mütevazi bir adamdı.
Biraz canım sıkkındı, dedim ki
"Mehmet bey, siz böyle yetenekleri
yetiştiriyorsunuz bu kulüpte.
Sonra bunları büyük kulüpler alıyor."
O zaman profesyonelleşme
yeni başlıyor voleybolda.
"Ne yapacağız? Bu insanların gitmesine
nasıl izin veriyorsunuz?
Bu kadar emek harcadınız, bu kadar
zaman harcadınız ve bu insanlar gidiyor.
Bunu nasıl önleyeceksiniz?" dedim.
On dört yaşlarında falanım
bu soruyu sorduğumda.
Bana dedi ki "Cem seni anlıyorum ama
ben bir daha yetiştiririm." dedi.
"Onlar" dedi "gitsinler, problem yok."
"Yenilerini yetiştiririm, onlar da giderse
yenilerini yetiştiririm ben."
Bu benim içimde bir şekilde
kalmış 35-40 senedir
nasıl olduğunu anlamadığım bir şekilde
ama kalmış olduğunu şöyle biliyorum:
Bugün arkadaşlarım geliyor
ajansta bana diyorlar ki
"Şu ajansa transfer oldu, yurt dışına
giden arkadaşlar var, ne yapacağız?"
Bazıları panik, bazıları üzgün geliyor.
Ne cevap verdiğimi tahmin
edebiliyorsunuz herhalde?
Biz de yenilerini yetiştiririz.
Buradan üç tane ders çıkarttım kendime.
Bir tanesi, Mehmet Fuat inanılmaz
kendine güveni olan bir adamdı bence.
Böyle bir söz söylemek için kendine
çok güvenmen gerekiyor,
sonsuz bir güvenin
olması gerekiyor sanıyorum.
İkincisi aslında o insan
yetiştirmek istiyordu.
İyi sporcular, ahlaklı adam gibi insanlar
yetiştirmek istiyordu bu topluma ve
spor dünyasına,
özellikle voleybol dünyasına.
Bunun için kendini vermişti bu işe.
Biz de uzun yıllardır sektöre
insan yetiştirmek için
çalışıyoruz diye düşünüyorum.
Çünkü herkesin böyle çalışması çok
önemli çünkü sektörün kalitesi yükseliyor
sizin yetiştirdiğiniz insanlarla,
başkalarının yetiştirdiği insanlarla.
Dolayısıyla nasıl büyütebilirsiniz bu işi,
nasıl daha iyi seviye getirebilirsiniz?
Bir üçüncüsü bence gizlice
gurur duyuyordu yaptığı işten.
Hiçbir zaman gururlanmadığı için,
mütevazi olduğu için bunu ben
kendim tahmini olarak söylüyorum.
Çünkü ben gurur duyuyorum
yetiştirdiğim arkadaşlarım gittiği zaman.
Üzülmüyorum, tam tersi gurur duyuyorum.
Dolayısıyla çok ilginç bir dersmiş
benim için sonradan belki öğrendim.
Bir başka konu bu kültürü
nasıl ileriye taşırsınız?
Bu kültürü yarattıktan sonra nasıl
ileriye doğru götürebilirsiniz?
Devamlı okumanız, devamlı
kendinizi geliştirmeniz gerekiyor.
Mehmet Fuat çok enteresan bir adamdı.
Bize Küba milli takımının
ağırlık programını getirirdi.
Canımızı çıkartırdı bütün yaz.
Eve gidemezdik veya gittiğimiz zaman
bir yere gidemezdik yorgunluktan.
Arada pembe yalanlar
söylerdi, sonradan öğreniyorduk.
Büyüdükten sonra öğrendik.
Bize derdi ki Japonya Milli Takımı
dağlara çıkıyor ve inanılmaz rüzgarların
olduğu bölgelerde pas antremanı yapıyor.
Biz inanılmaz dolduruşa
gelirdik, hemen dışarı çıkıp
rüzgarda pas yapardık
bütün yaz boyunca.
Hakikaten salona girdiğinizde
inanılmaz pas kaliteniz yükseliyordu.
Meğerse bunun pembe bir yalan
olduğunu daha sonra öğrendik.
Ama gidip Asya voleybolunu öğrenirdi,
gider Rusların blok tekniklerini öğrenip
bize o zamanki
slaytlarla bunları anlatırdı.
Her takıma nasıl hareket
edeceğimizi anlatırdı.
Şunu söylemeye çalışıyorum,
biz de kendi kendimizi
sürekli geliştirmeye çalışıyoruz.
Yeni şeyler öğrenmeye çalışıyoruz,
piyasaya yeni şeyler
getirmeye çalışıyoruz, dünyada olanları
takip etmeye çalışıyoruz.
Çünkü böyle bir koşu içerisindeyiz, bu
kültürü daha ileriye nasıl taşırız diye.
Daha da güzeli bize derdi ki en
iyi oyunu oynayacaksınız.
Çıkacaksınız ve öğrettiğim gibi
hızlı, karşı tarafı aldatan,
çok göze hoş görünen müthiş
bir oyun tarzımız vardı.
Bizim fanlarımız vardı.
Anadolu’ya gittiğimizde
Altınyurt’u seyretmeye gelen
insanlar vardı.
Bizi alkışlamaya, bunlar gelmişler
bu sefer ne yapacaklar diye
bizi arayan, oraya gelip bizi özel
seyreden insanlarımız vardı.
Bundan güzel bir şey olabilir mi?
Mehmet Beyin ödülü bu
oyunun oynanması ve alkıştı.
Hiçbir zaman şampiyonluklar ya da
madalyalar için bu işi yapmıyordu.
Zaten insan yetiştirmek için yapıyordu,
onları aldığımızda da onun
para ödülü de o oluyordu.
Biz de benzeri şekilde hareket ediyoruz.
Arkadaşlara yıllar önce şunu söylemiştim
"sıfırdan bir yerlerden başladık,
belki de sıfırda bir
yerde bırakacağız."
Çok da önemli bir iş yapmıyoruz. Ama bari
bu işi yaparken eğlenerek yapalım.
Mutlu bir ekibin, kreatif bir ekibin
çalışması işi de iyi çıkartıyor.
En iyi işe odaklandığınızda, en iyisini
aradığınızda ve bunu keyifle yaptığınızda
hep çocuklarımıza şimdi söylüyoruz
ya sevdiğin işi yap filan diye
biz yapamadık filan diye herkes
böyle birbirine anlatıyor.
Burada da sevdiğimiz bir işi
yapıyorduk voleybol oynarken de
şu anda da sevdiğimiz
bir işi yapıyoruz.
Çünkü o zaman sonuçlar çok iyi oluyor.
Belki de en önemlisi ve şu anda
da hala devam ettirmeye çalıştığım
bir profesyonel amatör
vardı aslında karşımızda.
Aslında şu anda ajansta bizim
yaşadığımız da böyle bir şey.
Bütün bunları amatör ruhla ve bir şey
beklemeden yapıyordu Mehmet Fuat.
O günkü koşullarda ve
hobisi olarak muhtemelen
ve gençler yetiştirmek istiyordu.
Biz de aynı şeyi ajansta mümkün olduğu
kadar parayla çalışan insanlar değil,
sevdiği için buraya gelen
reklamcılığı daha ileriye taşıyacak,
daha yaratıcı işler yapmak isteyen, daha
iyi işler yapmak isteyen insanlarla
o amatör ruhla benim profesyonel
amatör dediğim insanlarla yapıyoruz.
Tabi ki sonunda para kazanıyorlar.
Ama işi iyi yapmak, oraya konsantre
olmak çok daha önemli.
Aslında Mehmet Fuat benim hayatımda çok
ilginç bir rol oynadı diye düşünüyorum.
Ben devlet okullarına gittim, İngilizce'yi
yıllar sonra öğrendim belli bir
yaştan sonra. İyi bir üniversiteye
gitmedim, mühendis olmak istiyordum vs.
Ama 13 ile 20 yaşları arasında aslında
Mehmet Fuat’ın spor odaklı
hayat okulundan geçmişim meğerse.
Bunu belki de çok çok sonra öğrendim.
Ama baktım ki hayatımda hareket ettiğim,
yaptığım şeyler çok benziyor
bütün bu anlattıklarımla. Mehmet Fuat’ın
hikayesiyle spordaki hikayesiyle benziyor.
Onun edebiyatçı kişiliğini
sonradan öğrendim.
Edebiyatçı olduğunu bile bilmiyorduk
biz o zamanlar top oynarken.
Sonradan tanıştıkça, yaşadıkça ve
daha sonra kıymetini bildikçe
her şeyde olduğu gibi öğrendim.
Bilmiyorum belki hayat insanlara,
belki doktorlar bize pazarlamayı,
belki sanatçılar bize satışı, belki
edebiyatçılar bize sporu öğretiyordur.
Beni dinlediğiniz için
çok teşekkür ediyorum.
(Alkış)